researcher Western selected 150 glass  cups filled with strawberry jelly for  experimentation the first 50 cups were  placed into the Clockworks on the  setting rough the output produced was a  pile of glass shards and strawberry  jelly the second 50 cups were placed on  the setting one to one the output  produced was 50 cups made from hardened  strawberry jelly filled with molten  glass the final 50 cups were placed on  the setting very fine the output was a  glass item resembling an exact replica  of a human skull filled with strawberry  jelly note when the glass skull was  created it managed to move its jaw and  vocalize the word squish before becoming  inert again researcher Western